how's it going there citizens of the
reject Nation I am very excited because
we are back once again to check out The
Last of Us episode 2 Tara Erickson
joining me once again our good friend
the hilarious how are you feeling Tara
I'm feeling good I got big pants on
today they're real wide they come up
real high so if you guys see a bunch you
just they're big pants okay they're new
they're coming back in I'm trying to
bring them back in that's all I got to
say pants police be there in the
comments and as always leave a like on
the video that helps us out the most
upvote vote us upward in the algorithm
also subscribe hit that notification
Bell but don't take it from me take it
from Tara bring that back
ring the bell
all right all right all right all right
save it for the touring a little
flourished it's a little flourish and uh
hey if you want to get the full
experience with us come on over to
patreon.com real rejects you can sync up
with your own copy and enjoy the entire
Last of Us episode alongside Tara and I
it's a whole lot of fun we also got a
bunch of other shows and movies over
there with reaction highlights and watch
Longs included and if you haven't
already be sure to check out Greg and
Andrew's Last of Us reactions they are
the experts here at the real rejects
they played all the games and are pretty
much the entire reason why Tara and I
are able to be here and covering this in
the capacity that we are so go show them
some love yeah I'm nervous yeah
absolutely this has been so much fun and
uh thank you guys as well for uh being
so kind in the comments not spoiling
anything if you missed it last week we
are the noobs this is the blind noobs
reaction we haven't played the game we
don't know what's coming and uh and we
would like to keep that freshness alive
so thank you guys and uh let's hop to it
foreign
they talking about Jakarta in the first
episode
you're more important than you know
[Music]
yeah no cheating this is a test gloves
and masks anybody want to offer that
is
oh no
that's not supposed to happen
would you listen to the people in the
60s in the last episode
foreign
Jesus
that's not what you want to see
[Laughter]
oh please don't bite her fingers all
right I feel like obviously that's gonna
happen
why yeah oh God okay
oh oh
God I can't
I was moving a little bit get out oh God
yeah I don't blame you ladies
oh they're fine they're doing
this is a great long shot
um
wow
okay
foreign
I would like to die with my family
oh my goodness
God man that's right prologues
also when she pulled that out of the
guy's mouth I was like oh that looks
like spaghetti squash to me and now I
don't think I'll be able to eat
spaghetti squash not that I ate it a lot
because like who really eats a lot of
spaghetti Squad someone in the comments
does might not be able to
for a while
this is some very lovely credits music
as well which apparently apparently it's
the same composer who did the game music
oh I see I see
we're working with real pros here yes
that's true
do I look like I'm
coming show us your arm
worse is it
yet what was Marlene doing with an
infected kid I'm not infected she found
me after I Was Bitten and she didn't
shoot you clearly not
now can I please
back there you can find a spot
in here
there's not gonna be anything bad in
here just you
ouch guys
I get that it's a harsh World maybe a
hairline
it'll heal fast
you turning
God
love that little detail with his hand is
that chicken
yeah
probably until they get it from
it fight someone for a chicken
we're doing this for us because
apparently you're worth something
there's a firefly base camp somewhere
else
they're working on a cure I've heard
this before and whatever happened to me
I've seen this movie a dozen times
doesn't matter if she is or she isn't
what the fireflies say if they believe
that she is we get what we want
true that
she so much as twitches
oh my God careful oh my God girl
can I have a gun absolutely not
don't worry you'll get one you'll get a
gun someday
she she does have her people were very
very concerned to point that out
also apparently Joel dropping the wrench
as a tribute to the games oh
okay then
yeah
looks different in the daylight huh
[Music]
wow that looks insane
that is beautiful and horrifying is this
where they bombed
yeah
they hit most of the big cities like
this they had to slow the spread somehow
wow
they really took her advice
so the State House is across there it's
about a 10 minute walk if you could go
straight long way or short way
it's the long way or the whiff in dead
way huh
[Music]
I mean I would eat there today yeah you
know the old Mall in the QC
didn't think there was going to be
anything in there and then one just came
at me out of nowhere so it was just you
in there alone
how old are you
14. mommy you got some balls on you
sister yeah they're bonding they're
alike we're badasses together
what is going to be coming after you
right
and uh nude
new
the city was crazy
not exactly like that you know people
like to tell stories
so there aren't super infected that
explode fungus spores on you [__] I hope
not oh the ones with split open heads
that see in the dark like bats Easter
egg game Easter eggs I assume
oh no the sound I can't
the Ducks are immune good
oh my God
that's awesome
oh creepy whoa this set is amazing
yeah
all these sad Sandy exteriors you ever
stay in a place like this
ah no a little out of our league I don't
even know what this is have you heard of
books huh
it's more than just a billboard
the hits
oh no come on
no sound now would you like me
right away man
thank you oh my God
well we found the concierge
[Music]
all right well I mean maybe I could
climb up there and open it from the
inside uh no well I'm the smallest so
it'd be easier for me to
that you die and you get nothing
eyes on the price
[Music]
the knife needed to see it
got the knife
where are you from
Texas
what about Tess Detroit it's in Michigan
I go to school I know where Detroit is I
mean a lot of people went to school and
don't know where Detroit is how long do
infected live no I thought you went to
school
well some last about a month or two
but there's others been walking around
like 20 years
wow you have a good one
I killed lots of them
I killed so many of them
I got a necklace back home it's made of
ears
oh that's not a good look
oh
oh wow gnarly
oh my God you went inside so you can
shelter and that's how they get more and
more of the city bit by bit year after
year
whoa
oh why are they all wrote what's
happened today look for the light
step in Apache
and you can wake
it doesn't infect it from somewhere else
oh my goodness you're not immune from
being ripped apart it's important
I'm trying to keep you alive yeah Fair
what do we do then
short way
the fun way
[Music]
you put a big circular window it would
kind of look like the Sanctum sanctorum
okay
dude
that's a quarter steps I used to take it
all the time okay
okay well I don't pick it up what are
you attaching it for buddy
are mostly dead more ground rules we're
gonna go slowly if we come up against
anything we get behind us and you stay
there okay yes
what if something gets behind you
she did I have a spare hand
congratulations
not giving you a gun
take out your knife girl have it on the
ready Place yeah equip come on now
cool shot
you're welcome to the [__] Museum
laughs
sorry anytime anytime Boston is directly
I checked in the show
cooked
final reason
I guess we should have gone this way in
the first place
he doesn't look cooked he looks like
half cooked no no thank you that's fresh
well no questions
what if I have a question tariff
silent okay
I feel like you should be allowed to
talk if you're walking over those creaky
stairs at least at the level of the
creaking come on now
I mean
[Music]
Knuckles are white right
whoa oh no
no
something's lurking
[Music]
oh stock up yeah
they found the treasure
the most useful room in the museum I
feel like I'm gonna wheel this just this
cannon yeah
oh okay yep
oh
[Music]
at least no one's coming in behind you
no yep
oh my God hold out your knife like
[Music]
yep yes
oh [__] yep
oh yeah get the gun in there
[Music]
they move based on sound
rather than sight
wow
oh
my God kill it break that cabinet with
all the guns
yeah it's every musket oh my God one of
them has to have like a oh my God come
on or something come on come on come on
okay
uh take the bus yeah that's heavy oh
[Music]
foreign
okay
this is gonna be right there I don't
want it
whatever you say boss
oh damn oh
[Music]
my God okay lady come in shoot it yeah
somebody I don't oh
what how are you up again already oh
thank God yeah you gotta like obliterate
his head
[Applause]
yes thank you Tess yes
yes an ax
God's head looks like a bunch of ratio
or something oh yeah
is there is there a special name for the
for this kind comment below there's got
to be a variety of infected right
no there's no come on now we're going to
carry you and all right
I mean
it's okay if you did but yeah
Pride like
I mean if it was gonna happen to one of
us
[Laughter]
break the freaking gun cabinet please
yeah
one of those old muskets must work
or something
bludgeoned somebody's head sure
it's going to be a bayonet in there come
on now
poke poke
yeah I know it looks scary that was
scary
oh my God
just wait there give us a minute
oh no don't have the talks don't have to
leave me behind talk
about the kid
can you give me the first bite can take
it I should just take the good news
no they did it for once maybe we can
actually win
damn didn't even look
is that everything you hoped for
jury's still out
can't deny that
come on let's get the before it's dark
oh good
she's in a mood
rightfully so
yeah oh God
she knows her time is limited yeah it
sucks I like her I'm rooting for you
Tess me too
[Music]
wow
show yourself
ah damn it [__] is going on I don't know
they went inside
cheers
[Music]
Tess has had it test just wants that
damn battery and a call it a day
which I do not blame her for oh okay
who killed them Petra each other
themselves
about the sick ones everyone lost huh
where did Marlene say that she was
taking you uh I don't know just west so
can you help me no no
it's over we are going home it's not my
[__] home
huh
that's right
our luck had to run out sooner or later
show me oh
no sad
oh damn it
ugh
cut off a piece of your skin make her
eat it see if it works like come on now
yeah I fixed this Ellie come on
oh
and you said everything right
yep
oh no
oh God now that it's all going to grow
they gotta get out of there yeah nice
little Squadron built right in oh my
goodness
wow God these makeups oh geez oh my God
yep yep yep yep oh damn it no oh my God
such a great device oh you feel a
beautiful shot coming on she's staying
behind and she gets eaten by a dozen of
them
I don't want her to but how many oh
maybe a minute
car batteries
get all the car batteries and light them
up
what are you doing making sure that they
don't follow you
oh going out like a hero
oh yeah
yeah slide it up
oh
just pull the pin along those grenades
oh Tess come on no oh cause she's one of
them do they not like yeah they must be
ignoring her yeah
join us
who is it from your past life
no please please
oh
my God what oh
[Music]
that reminds me of every date where the
guy was a bad kisser
oh my gosh no you don't want the the
tendrils in your no in your business
[Music]
you are alone in the world
wow
that was a lot it's so good yeah all
right it's so good
damn
and now I'm like I can't wait to play
the video game except also like I don't
know if I can handle having my heart
broken as frequently as I imagine you
must
yeah no no never the game and also if
you hurt my stomach growling for the
first 45 minutes of this reaction I'm
sorry you're infected
how has that even happen to a person for
that long weird
anyway I should eat before I come here
that's what we learned from this episode
most of this the the ensuing review will
be about you know your eating habits and
how we can fix this
as it should be all right well let's
talk about it ah
man
what you call John
I mean where does it start like I love I
love the gradual unfolding that this has
been like you know I love
the Resurgence of you know like episodic
like week to week TV and yet I'm also
sitting here wondering like man these
these must be fascinating to watch like
in a tandem just because of how
gracefully it seems one is flowing into
the next and the story is getting on its
way and yeah you know you you set
everything up in the previous one you
you get the new status quo and I liked
it here you get another flash back to
you know the significant events or just
you know like a little glimpse into the
before time but also in relation to you
know what's to come what we're going to
spend most of our time with and then
here you know on the heels of the last
episode striking out and now you get
just that first taste of the surrounding
world and it's fun because
being that this is a video game
adaptation you know I'm not sitting here
constantly like the form of this isn't
constantly reminding me about that
however I do think that they have done
kind of an interesting job of making
each episode feel like a level almost or
feel like a new area to explore so it's
like here you know you get the outer
perimeter of the qz and you get you know
sort of the The First Taste of the
frontier that's to come and yeah I just
thought there was so much tension
watching as they figure out how to sneak
and using Ellie as you know your sort of
audience Cipher to then you know give us
that information about like okay well
yeah don't just willy-nilly step on
anything and everything because you know
the fungus is connected it's a network
and all these creatures all these
infected people are part of that Network
to some degree and yeah it can Decay but
chances are you know yeah should
probably err on the side of caution and
yeah just like the way they're building
the lore in the world I think has been
really uh just super engrossing and
really intense so far like I love
it it makes me again curious as to what
the balance in like the game of action
versus sneaking in suspense is like
because this feels like you know part of
the charm is that you know a lot of it
is just the Eerie you know atmospheric
tension and then when something really
does go down it packs that much more of
a punch you know yeah I also okay in the
first episode there's a butterfly
stainless steel butterfly hanging from
their apartment and the girl was sitting
in front of that thing for like a long
time in the shot and then when you first
reveal her in this episode a butterfly
goes atop her right yep I'm like
where what what's the deal with the
butterfly I'm right now I'm like why are
the animals are surviving but then we
saw the Ducks and the Frog I don't know
there's some butterfly thing and if no
butterflies come up in the videogram
then that's just me and I'm being crazy
but it did make me think like is a
butterfly a key to this virus or is it
just a symbol of Hope
um and maybe it's just surrounding the
girl because the girl is
she's like virus come at me I will
survive
um maybe it's a like a metamorphosis
symbol yeah something yeah that got in
my head while you were talking even this
it was all it was a left turn I realized
that I didn't piggyback on top of what
John was saying maybe it's a thing that
people in the comments look at
butterflies in the game yeah butterflies
and also like when you play the game do
you get to be like select Museum and
then you go into the museum which is
what you were saying like leveling up
like different levels where you see now
we see this part of the world meaning
next episode I wonder what we would get
to and I'm pretty stoked about that yeah
and now I guess it's just going to be
Ellie and Joel I was so bummed I was so
bummed for tests like I I like that they
I mean I'm sure this conversation
surrounding this show will just
inevitably have The Walking Dead be a
part of it and you know it's like
flashing back to those early Walking
Dead episodes especially the first
season episodes you know there there's a
similar sense of error and here you know
they have a similar sense like anything
could happen and nobody is really safe
and I wonder I'm I'm
you know the show has been very well
received so far and these first two
episodes have been terrific and so I
don't really have any doubt that they'll
maintain a certain you know Baseline but
yeah I'm curious to see how characters
from here will be introduced and how
just will be killed as well yeah yeah
how many again little heart breaks will
be along the way because this does seem
like a world where it would be very hard
to you know maintain an ensemble without
any casualties
um but yeah no it's it's very effective
and I thought the way they handled that
whole thing of of her being bitten and
not revealing it you know quite until
you know when [__] really has has gotten
dire
yeah yeah like it's it's a Trope but I
thought they handled it really nicely
here and you know now it's funny it's
like the first episode ends in a way
where you feel like okay
now we're about to really set off on the
adventure and then this episode ends and
you're like okay so the fireflies
weren't there and the drop can't be made
now we're gonna really start of the
adventure yeah you know and hopefully
run into veteran Combat on the way
brother brother is still alive he's out
there I believe it he can take care of
me he's gonna come through for them and
then he will probably die no yeah I know
I don't want him to maybe he won't I
don't want him to but I'm like he'll
have the plot armor this feels very Game
of Thrones you're like you really start
to like a character you better watch out
they're going to be dead in like a
couple of weeks yeah exactly does any
any of your favorite characters beware
yeah but yeah like it's it's funny
because because it does feel so big and
the way they uh just I'm always
fascinated like I would love to see a
behind the scenes of how they did the
ruins and everything because there's a
lot you can do with volumes and and CG
and whatnot but it's a very convincing
you know post-apocalyptic Wasteland that
they through here and I like that they
touch on especially through Ellie the
idea that like this is all kind of
beautiful and also scary and and you
know sad and and run down
yeah I feel like with that line she's
like but you can't beat that view and he
looks at her and is like oh it's he's
registering now that she's not just an
ordinary 14 year old yeah she's she
feels a lot older and I think that once
they get to know each other he'll
realize that they're kind of on the same
playing field yeah I think in regards to
intelligence and her instincts sure I
think she has good instincts she does
and she's gonna bring his soul back yeah
she's gonna teach him that there's that
there's still good warmth in in this
life and not everything is dire and car
batteries open up his heart like a
little butterfly that's right
his heart's just a shriveled caterpillar
right now yeah it's like the Grinch's
heart and then you know he's gonna have
a
Whoville celebration but just with her
somehow without the weird people they'll
celebrate and then his heart will grow
three sizes unless they say what I'm
saying a metamorphosis yeah oh that's
good John John got it what I'm here for
man you got it you need a portmanteau
I'm your guy I'm your Port man
well any other stray thoughts before we
Boogie
no I'm just still mad they didn't break
the cabinet and take those really old
guns that may or may not shoot they may
have one weird bullet in them but you
guys know how I feel about weapons I'm
like take them all yeah yeah for sure
um and that that's it I mean it's all
really really good stuff and I would
also like a behind the scenes on how
they shot that because I know they're
shooting on real land just in all right
like a warehouse right but then the
buildings I'm like if it's all CGI it's
not all green screen I feel like they
have some fake buildings they're
shooting in a city in one area but then
I'm like do they just drop it in or do
they have to like green screen a
building close to drop in to make it
look that real this is where my brain
goes and I would also like a behind the
scenes
those are all of my thoughts you're
probably not too far off it's funny it's
funny because this episode is like
it's like pretty straightforward it's
just like really tense and really
immediate and I think that's a that's a
nice quality because like the first
episode is so there's so much setting up
the world and you have this prologue and
then you also have the establishment of
everything else and what Society has
become and now I feel like this this was
like a very patiently intense episode so
uh it's also kind of neat is like I'm
wondering what the the I'm wondering how
the flavors of the episodes will
progress as we go along too yeah and if
they'll be any more weird kissing like
do they do that do they are they like
you're almost there let's make out so we
can get you there like implant the you
know what I mean is that how they I
couldn't tell if it was that she
probably knew the guy she did stop I do
believe that you're like it might be
someone from our passage she's like
Bobby yeah and he's like what he wants
to kiss her like one I don't know it's
weird it may be I'm like maybe there's a
maybe there's a little little tiny bit
of that uh like like Dawn of the Dead
Day of the Dead like they they retain
certain base elements of who they used
to be and so in that moment I mean she
certainly seemed like she did recognize
that guy or or or something I don't know
what it was or maybe she was struck by
his recognition of her for whatever
reason but yeah I kind of took that as
like maybe this this this was who you
lost and in this sick tragic way you're
like well
we'll kiss one last time before it all
goes up
absolutely but everybody's waiting for
well hey cordyceps slap that like button
leave your thoughts down below
non-spoiler thoughts of course you guys
were very considerate about that last
week we appreciate you dearly and uh
yeah I just cannot wait to continue this
this is this is so freaking cool stoked
absolutely well guys be well and hey
before we skedaddle let's do a patron of
the day shout out yeah
Everett pixel might Baker my dude I hope
you're doing well if there was an
apocalypse upon us I would want you in
the camp with us something about you
something about you know he can bake
that's true he can bake he's Mighty uh
maybe much like a pixel he can be
crammed into tight spaces if there is
sneaking to be done or many desserts to
be made absolutely Gotta Have desserts
in the apocalypse that's the thing like
Ellie's got sandwiches but I'm talking
where's the ice cream sandwiches oh man
Everett you could be that guy supplying
in Everett like just what a nice sturdy
name to kick it all off you could be the
person in the camp keeping everyone's
Spirits High bringing us treats and
whatnot and everyone's like where do you
get that stuff man in your life Baker
I'm a baker I made it my somehow with
the apocalypse people are shanking each
other for chickens but not me nope got
all the Confections you could want
infections to Stave off infections oh
that's just good dude Everett you just
bring you just bring out the bars in us
you know we're gonna drop a mixtape
based on you
appreciate you being here with us for so
long and uh yeah we'll catch you next
month be well buddy and uh much love